[Music]
you know there's a great line by Carl
Sagan that says that understanding is a
kind of ecstasy right that we are
cognitive beings we are creatures of
mind we have natural inquiry embedded in
our bones right curiosity defines us we
are the frontal lobes of the universe
but it's also said that in life
happiness comes not from finding the
answers but in seeking better questions
right and so in the age of the internet
or any query where any piece of data
knowledge or insight is a Google search
way you come to wonder are we living in
a world where wonder is expressed more
intensely because at any time I wonder
about something I can look up the answer
or is the immediacy with which the
answer is available actually dulling us
into a state where we rarely experience
the rapture of discovery the rapture of
the search right not just the
destination but the journey expressed as
the labor the search the curiosity
seeking to satiate itself and so it
makes you wonder will this simply open
up new vistas new questions we haven't
thought of yet are we
offloading the simple questions to the
neuro sphere and making room for new
things we haven't even thought of yet I
mean I like to think so because I'm an
optimist you know unlike Socrates who
felt that the invention of writing would
atrophy our brains because we wouldn't
have to remember anything as we wrote it
down so two people worry that today's
technologies are gonna atrophy part of
our brain and limit what it means to be
human but I think it won't I think it
will literally offload some
functionality and open up new vistas
just like every technology that came
before so that's what I think
[Music]
you